[Musique]
pour moi
m
ma
tu parles d'un porte arrière je suis
entré
m
est-ce que ça va
bonjour
très sûrs
je fais ressortir
suite
pour qui
j'établis contact on va sortir
je
[Musique]
le match
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]
bande de minables on croyait être des
movies pente de minables au croyais être
demande des marines ont versé leur sang
pour le corps des marines des marines
sont morts pour le corps et vous croyez
que vous méritez de mourir avec autant
d'honneur gérard j'ai dit vous croyez
que vous méritez de mourir avait autant
de l'air on dirait que vous avez tous
peur vous êtes peut-être heureux d'être
de moorings mais on dirait que vous avez
peur c'est pour cette raison que j'ai
été introduit dans notre vie le bout de
papier que vous tenez compte et le
numéro de série de votre arme vous à les
mémoriser ce numéro ainsi qu'une
multitude d'autres informations que je
considère nécessaire
est-ce que c'est clair serge heures
est-ce que c'est clair est-ce que cet
argent tu comprends que tu tiens bon pop
in win win sergio n'y étais ce petit
bout de papier
combien paient ce petit bout de papier a
dit le sergent rend bien cadiou serveurs
rien du tout au sérieux alors pourquoi
tes bras faiblissent
pourquoi tes bras faiblissent pourquoi
tes bras faiblissent pourquoi tes bras
faiblissent dis moi pourquoi mais moi
pourquoi ni moi pourquoi l'ancien joueur
tu sais pas pourquoi j'ai pas faibli
n'en sais rien révélé c'est un foutu
brut papier tenez vous prêts à être
poussée au delà de vos limites
tenez vous prêts à en baver jour après
jour jusqu'à ce que vous soyez dignes
d'être appelé lorsque l'ennemi d'hier à
al attaques relèvent les bras ramasseux
soyez prêts à souffrir marines devraient
souffrir était plus fort dirigez-vous
deux par deux sur le parcours aller
[Musique]
dans ce
passez au suivant passez au suivant plus
d'une route à l'est
[Musique]
le flanc
on y va rester à l'avant
bref on y va
à
on donne pas
darwin a offert au ballet studio
terrorisme
testé par les mauriciens
de dire pourquoi tu réponds pour lui
vous coucher dans même lit mourir
deux boucles vite que ça me regarde
ça
[Musique]
tu as la bouche pleine de mer mourir
sauf sergent
ça s'anime
comment voulez faire partie d'une bise
comment on s'y retrouver ici c'est la
faute des dauphins qui crèvent ça le
truc les dos au mur
[Musique]
robert du monde
du moment qu'on soit environ sont
attendus vendredi
[Musique]
tu vois quelque chose
il faut
on peut crever de celui-là il cela
certains on y va bien
[Musique]
quand
on se marre de toi par terre dans quoi
tu y es tu on est des marines à la
moindre connerie je te fais sauter la
cervelle c'est compris qui tu as les
réponses qui es tu je m'appelle je
respire respire
je recherche des survivants
tu comprends ce que tu dis moi qui est
arrivé ici
avec jacky à toute la planète pourquoi
cette app affectés pour que ça tape
affectés
pourquoi le monde entier est dévastée et
doigté pas affectée l'ère des vos
compliments pour quelqu'un qui voudrait
les entendre tous notre antenne alzonne
et des survivants des toits j'ai mes
amis j'ai tout au monde où ce dimanche
où sont-ils et reste pas dire
c'est quoi ça
sa perfidie
[Musique]
j'étais dans les mairies il ya très
longtemps
c'était dans une autre vie ça plus
d'importance et nous ont tous abandonné
dans cet enfer visa
key
terme les yeux être pas les yeux quand
j'aurai appliquer le poivre de cayenne
compression respire profondément
retourne toi quand tu es prêt attention
je vaporise
[Musique]
pour les yeux combien je dois aux grands
les yeux doux sergent avance vas-y vas-y
vas-y vas-y des baisses d impôts appris
des syndicats tuc acheter qu'un
dégagement des caniches âge légal qui
cache google tout qu'est ce que tu fous
là
pourquoi tu te rates les yeux je vois
plus rien c'est évidemment tu vois rien
thébaux 6 sites fermés
si tu penses que tu devrais faire pour
régler ce problème trouverez mes yeux
sont jamais loin la jetta la solution et
c'était pas si difficile un relève la
tête et pointe son museau les yeux sur
la fibre gavois fars
ah ah
pas magnifique
tout le monde
brand de sacrifices et de prédation
la douleur ne diminue pas quand les
tenir talent à plus de bruit vers le
site et pas les bonnes moeurs de plus
vite
musique
[Musique]
très content
allez mon frère
bien que quelques applaudissements qui
prépare ce n'est jamais qu'un
j'ai par les sonneries
ça brille comme une [ __ ] pour marcher
nos marchés ça va aller mon frère
certainement
pén italie qu'est ce que tu viens de
dire
qu'est ce que tu as dit non
j'avais dit oui il a dit johnny je suis
sûr
tu reconnais l'enfant sur la photo
un office
c'est de la foutaise
non c'est de la foutaise il ment
l'attitude ni et la prononcer le nom de
ton fils crois moi
il l'a dit
continuer notre route